and to do
enjoy
there are those who say that there are
only 36 literary plots in the world and
they just get reused over and over there
are others who say that there are merely
20 plots some people go so far as to say
that there is only one plot but I think
those people have been watching too many
Michael Bay movies personally of all the
theories out there I prefer the one that
says that there are seven basic plots
seven is a reassuring number and the
categories are big enough that anything
from Citizen Kane to a breakfast cereal
commercial can be fit into them in fact
I like it so much that in the spirit of
grandiose oversimplification I'm going
to provide my own contemporary take on
the subject and thus i present the seven
basic blog posts number one be upset
terrible things are happening in one of
the following the world the web or a TV
show you like post about it on your blog
people will read it and agree with you
in the comments they'll post about it on
their blog people will read it and agree
with them in the comments and then we
will learn that when we all work
together we can make a real difference
in our page views number two by a thing
for too long mainstream media has shoved
advertising down our throats it's time
for us to take the reins of mass
communication and shove advertising down
each other's throats and maybe if we're
all watching the same overproduced films
and buying the same overpriced gadgets
then the bitter wind of loneliness won't
buy quite so fiercely number three
animals are cute people don't seem to
like animals when they act like animals
if you put up a photo of a cat snapping
a robin's neck it's not going to go
viral now we prefer when we can think of
our pets as being just like us only with
were spelling for the purposes of this
category animals includes babies and
children under eight number four people
are dumb try the following put up videos
of yourself volunteering at a soup
kitchen giving a speech at a symposium
and breaking your arm playing shopping
cart luge guess what
one is going to get the most hits it
seems we like our animals smarter than
they really are but our people dumber
than they really are which I suppose
means that the ultimate internet
celebrity would be a somewhat
slow-witted centaur and a Darth Vader
outfit number five something I like only
different liking new things takes so
much effort you have to learn about new
characters and remember new lyrics no
it's much easier to find something you
already like what kind of a little spin
on it The Matrix acted out by
gingerbread men lord of the rings but if
frodo was a ninja the Super Mario
Brothers theme played on the
hollowed-out skulls of owls we're
actually reaching the third iteration of
this Star Wars except with homemade
lightsabers except on a weezer video and
in about 10 seconds we're going to get
the fourth iteration when someone takes
that video and recut sit in Lego form
number six weird science this includes
people's homemade experiments involving
explosives other people's insane
personal theories and if you must actual
scientific studies but if you're going
to link to a scientific study you need
to take one of two approaches first off
if you disagree with the conclusions you
need to say this is totally false and
biased I can't believe that scientists
get paid to disseminate this kind of
falsehood on the other hand if you agree
with their conclusions you have to say
this is completely obvious i can't
believe that scientists get paid to say
things that everyone already knows
either way you're educating your readers
that you're smarter than every scientist
in the world number 7 me we've reached
the point in history where egotism is
considered too much work so instead of
actually talking about your life your
hopes your fears you just go and fill
out a quiz or get a cartoon version of
yourself or you just sit back and
collect friends it's a good thing that a
nice nin wasn't a blogger because
instead of getting a sensual tale of
sexual awakening and
creative fervor we just learned that if
she was a teenage mutant ninja turtle
she'd be Raphael